good morning John maybe not quite like
this this seems a little bit much
are you sure just ignore them just
ignore them no
talk to me you talk to me you talk to me
we're at Grace Helbig and memory Hearts
vacation rental the highball house in
Palm Springs California I'm hiding
something if somebody ever stays here
okay it's just a note that I've written
on the underside of something wow just
defacing the property putting things on
things it's a trash can older than none
pizza with left beef
our marriages oh but only by one year oh
Andy wants to know what's the your
favorite video we've made together I
don't know I like answering questions
but I think that the the best one we
ever did was where we cooked that those
bad old foods that is the best one well
you can't it's so I mean it's one of the
like hardest I've ever worked on a
fuller Brothers video for like no
results yeah it's not like any of that
food that's good well that's no we never
went back to any of those recipes no
who's your favorite Mr Darcy original Mr
Darcy extra tasty crispy Mr Darcy from
like just book Mr Darcy yeah who's your
favorite person who's played Mr Darcy
yes Colin first yeah
Miss Bennett relatedly but not really
who's your favorite person on Taskmaster
I really want to know if we say the same
person you can't beat Bob Mortimer I'm
not gonna uh in any kind
whatever is my number one I can't beat
Bob more tomorrow morning
whoever that guy is is up there too
would you rather fight one Hank sized
Pelican or four pelican-sized Hanks oh
four Pelican sized tanks
for sure but I'm like nice and you like
me would you rather hug one Hank sized
Pelican or four Pelican sized tanks hey
size pellets oh no
I'm sorry I want to hug a bunch of
little knees nah I see that do you have
a favorite Hank Green song trying to
think about concert the universe is
weird oh yeah that's a super fun one
live that one's awesome live yeah
because everybody gets real weird we
turn that into like a Jam song yeah and
I'm always in the audience for universes
but I'm like down in there I'm like all
right come what's your favorite pizza in
the shirt this year
that one is really good Lauren says that
he's like why are you always wearing
Pizza John why is pizza John everywhere
could a spherical Pizza have toppings on
both the inside and the outside how
would you cook it I mean you could
definitely imagine like sort of
mathematical like like a conceptual like
Mobius strip Pizza Mobius strip pizza oh
and then finally from Josie can or
should Hank grow a mustache you're
welcome to girl mustache if you would
like it you're always learning something
new even after 17 years I thought that
the answer to that was going to be no
end no yeah I definitely cannot grow a
mustache uh branding wise oh yeah no
yeah that's a whole other that's a whole
other glass Catherine thank you for
being married to me for 16 years
uh thank you for the wildest way it
could possibly have gone
uh John Happy Pizza mess we'll see you
on Wednesday
but it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
in my
[Music]
right now
[Music]